very good so on a more serious note
we're going to have a talk now about
impress analytical data management duct
B I would like to have a big round of
applause for Dr hannes please come to
the stage thank you very
much hi guys uh super excited to be here
uh it's not very often that I just you
know vote across town to go speak to
people and uh today has been really
exciting um because it's um yeah it's I
think really exciting for me to talk to
you about adduct but also just um you
know really really happy to get to talk
about things that we have been working
on for so long and I have to make a
small correction I'm one of the fers of
D the other one is my grassel for
sitting up here and it's like very much
a sort of you know two people sort of
thing that we that we started there um
I'm going to talk a bit about the
rationale of DB a bit like the story
behind and going to give you some demos
if there's time and I'm also going to
you know show you a neverbe secret new
project that we've been working on um so
uh you know stay tuned so for some
background um this is a very very very
unexciting looking building in Amsterdam
it's the CWI the Dutch national research
lab for Computer Science and Mathematics
although the mathematics people say it's
the other way around um and who knows
what happened in this building Pyon was
invented um and I we happened to work we
happen to work there uh some some years
ago Mark and I in a a group that was
doing data management research and we
talked to a lot of data science people
I'm sure even though this is like the
wrong frenchise you have maybe have
heard of Hadley Wickam he's one of the
guys that is really active in R and we
talked to him about databases and then
he put this like on the internet
statement right you know if your data
fits in memory there is no advantage of
putting it into database it will only be
slower and more
frustrating and that really hurt our
feelings
okay and we go like okay we can now hate
Hadley or we can actually think about
why databases are frustrating and we
have kind of here we have two guys and I
know I'm old and this movie is even
older but there's the good and then
there's the bad let's start with the bad
uh databases are frustrating because you
have to install them or you have to even
worse you have to kind of bribe your
admin with pizza or something to install
them um then you have to bribe them even
more to maintain the thing you know
upgrade the version or whatever um and
then you also have to
this very annoying uh problem of getting
data in and out of them and this is
something that uh is one of these things
that gets you as your data set gets
bigger now everything is like happy
happy for small things but then as it
gets bigger it becomes really
frustrating and we actually wrote a
research paper a couple of years ago on
why that is if you're interested in why
that is check it
out however there's also a lot of good
things about data management systems
like query optimization is what this
thing where you know we take the uh sort
of the data analysis question from a
user and we reason about it and be like
okay if we move these things around it
will be faster that's pretty useful I
would say persistence you know like the
original rationale for building data
management systems back in like the 60s
was that everybody was was running
around on these text file zoos with like
hand handc coded programs and then if
you think about like python programs on
CSV files that's like exactly the same
problem but data management system uh
they provide persistence and you know
you know clean changes of data with
transaction and such so that's nice um
and of course there's efficiency like we
this is field that I'm sort of grew up
in data management research has spent a
gazillion years in you know making
things fast and so we thought maybe
there's a way of kind of working on the
bad a bit and then preserving the good
and another way of looking at it is this
um that I like I like looking at is is
this um Burger thing here right where
the thing that caused the problems or
caused the frustration was that nobody
had looked at sort of the endtoend user
experience of Data Systems everybody had
been sort of hyperfocused on the engine
like the meat the Patty or if you want
like the veggie thing doesn't really
matter everybody had been focusing on
that and nobody had really looked at the
end to-end experience so Mark and I you
know sitting there going like okay we
have to do something the world hates us
uh we have to come up with something new
knew we were St trying to think of ways
in which we can overcome the source of
frustration and preserve like the the
good things and that is what led to duck
DB so duck DB is a data management
system it's very classic you know think
data based people call it uh it's built
from scratch we WR it together with now
many more people because the team has
grown quite a bit um it is I will
explain it's an inprocess data
management system management system a
lot like sqlite
um and it's built really to give you
very very hard uh fast state-ofthe-art
execution engine so you get a very high
efficiency together with all the
features that make data management
systems nice like persistence um and the
best thing is it's free so it's MIT
licensed you know you can just use it
question we always get why is it called
dub it's because I'm even crazier than
people think and I just used to have a
duck that's
it um
um Let Me Go a bit about sort of the
things that make DB special so first is
simple we found that a lot of
frustration of people using data
management systems came from the fact
that they're terrible to install set up
maintain you know get get going with so
if anybody has ever installed postgress
and had to edit this funky file to
actually allow your tool to connect you
will know what I'm talking about um so
dub is simple it's it's it's meant to be
extremely simple to use so and one key
component of simple to use uses that we
found was that in process is really
something that allows simplicity so if
you have ever used seek for light there
is no like database server you know
people think about this two-tier system
but it's not there it's sqlite it's just
in whatever process you have it's even
built into python um dub is the same way
the data management system runs within
whatever process you're in this can be a
python process this can be God forbid
and R process it can be Java you know it
doesn't really matter it's whatever it
it can run in your t low for sake
um it but it also has means that in
process has this really big Advantage if
you're sitting in the same address space
the same process as the thing you're
kind of working with then you have a
very efficient data transfer because
there is no transfer you just you know
look at pointers in memory I'm going to
show this in the demo in a bit another
thing about Simplicity is that we have
no dependencies like there is no there
is no dependencies in dub like you just
do pip install dub and it's not like
downloading like warrant piece from you
know from piie uh it's just like Boop
that's it it's like 20 megabytes binary
or something like that and this of
course a lot of work right like you have
to if you're not if you can't like use
other people's stuff or have to sort of
work around that it's a lot of work but
we did that so you don't have to suffer
um it runs anywhere like mac Linux
Windows who cares um and it's actually
getting quite popular we have about 1.5
million downloads a month at the moment
from piie alone and that's only one of
the platforms that we use but simple
doesn't mean it's like some simple thing
like sqlite that I don't know doesn't
understand types or something like that
it actually is Qui feature which it has
a very wide SQL dialect we have
transactions persistence crazy joins
Aggregates window functions it can
directly read Park files uh CSV files
and Json files in parallel and efficient
and yada yada y so it's actually the
feature set that you would more expect
from more sort of bigger systems like I
don't know pogress or I don't know
anything else like
that and again simple doesn't mean you
know dumb simple means can also be fast
it's simple but it also is
state-of-the-art and that comes out of
our background as being researchers at
the CWI in the like state-of-the-art
data management research where like how
can you make these things fast and I was
talking to the team is like how can we
explain what makes dctp fast and they're
like it's very simple just say it's
magic
um of course we know that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic um but you
have to think about like this way it's a
culminations of Decades of research in
data management systems there's like
tons of PhD thesis that whose results
have gone into the concepts that make
dctb fast and one thing that you can
kind of see this with is you like you
you you know run dctb with something and
you type a query and you go go and it
just goes like map and use all it makes
your laptop hot it's a downside I have
to say so if you're sitting in the train
you may want to reduce the you know the
the degree of parallelism a bit but DB
automatically paralyzes everything that
you do over all the CPU course that you
have and this is just on my MacBook
which has like 10 cores these days but
the thing is what we've learned with
looking at the scaleout people like
spark is that blind um paralyzation is
not enough really to get good efficiency
you also really need a good efficiency
if you're only running on a single core
so we achiev this by you know again
being crazy and um spending a lot of
time optimizing individual operators in
in C++ uh dctb can also use directly
your disk if it the memory should not be
enough to complete a specific operation
you know you can also say ha okay I may
be out of memory here but there's a ton
of dis space sitting here and with the
ssds um these days it's not a problem
and this again this all happens
completely
automatically which why to the user it
can can look like
magic and it's free um yeah we come out
we come out of this we come out of the
same place as python so of course it's
free but uh um it is free in open source
software we you know we open source you
can do whatever you
want python is actually the I think I
would say at this point the the main
sort of one of the main apis that we
developed du before like we features
that come to duck DB always will have a
m way to reach them from the python API
it is the one of the primary apis and
lots of Cutting Edge features are coming
there first I will demo one of them
later I also want to mention this one
really nice aspect of being in the same
process being in process if you for
example you're sitting there in your
python shell and you have a ginormous
pandas data frame sitting there dub can
directly read that pandas data frame as
if it were a table and that works really
well because you're sitting in the same
process basically we taught uh our query
execution engine how to interpret the
bits on in memory that make a pandas
data frame and we just look at it and
and read it directly into queries I'll
show that in the demo the same thing
also works with arot tabl so if you have
Arrow table or even an arrow stream
object sitting there in memory you can
directly query this with duct DB without
having to do any sort of these typical
import steps or whatever you do okay so
now I'm going to show you a quick demo
um uh I I'll share the script later so
you can can play this uh up so I need to
un mirror my
screen so you can see what I'm on to can
you see
oh not
yet
um can we um get
the projection working
please
Ah that's better should I do
something
no but it's better than
nothing that's okay I mean I can Al I
could also try to work around it if you
want should we do
something I get extra time while we're
doing this let's let's take a question
there hases anyone got a question yes
okay thank you for breaking the awkward
silence thank you sir we like you very
good no since you mentioned it works
directly with a arrow I imagine it will
work directly with polers
yes you can Pol has can can go can
export it it is built on Apache Arrow so
you can basically read the error
structures directly from DV yes you can
um more more question yes yes there's a
question there
cool so did I do something wrong no it's
all good no it's okay it's okay it's all
good well I want to ask actually like uh
how was the transition process from a
research project to an actual company
you know like uh we see that happening a
lot in us but like in Europe this is
quite limited so what were the
challenges you faced there um that's a
great question what were the challenges
to go from a research project it was
quite gradual I want to say say but like
the step to um to go go from like being
in this like coddled environment of a
research institute to basically running
your own company that was a big step I
it has happened before in our group
people in data management they tend to
do spin-offs so it wasn't that there
wasn't any ah thank you Ty wasn't any
precedent great demo time can you read
this in the back hello back okay
um so I'm just going to run python here
and then uh very like shocking I know
um import a bunch of stuff this is the
the usual dance and then here in this uh
snippet what I'm generating is a data
frame in pandas just random uh data of
like two million rows it's not very big
it's like 16 megabytes or something like
that right um and then I'm connecting to
postgress which is like what many people
will be used to when working with
databases and they will be hating it
because they will be frustrated and I'm
not doing also a connection to to duct
here and then for unknown reasons for
reasons only known to the pandas
maintainers I also have to use the SQL
alemy thing here um and now let's just
run some sort of very basic timings um
I'm going to use the pandas two SQL
thing which basically writes a data
frame to a to a table in the Target
system so this is writing to pogress and
now we can do another
question I was
joking it should complete there we go 15
seconds so this is not a particular
huge data set but it took 15 seconds now
I told you all about the Miracles of
inmemory
um 2 milliseconds with activv okay and
that is actually not that's no trickery
there this is actually written to dis
and whatnot like this is 2
millisecs um because it's only 16
megabytes and like how long do it takes
takes it does it take to write 16
megabytes to disc right not 15 seconds
um and now we can do the inverse we can
again use the pandas feature to read a
table from a
postris database here and it's 1.5
seconds a bit faster but you will not be
surprised to see that uh DV again is
much faster and the nice thing is like I
I had to scale these numbers so I don't
have to wait here for 20 minutes until
something is done so obviously as you
make the data set bigger than 16 megabit
megabyte God forbid this will be more
pronounced um so now um what I also want
to show is a kind of a neat trick that
we made where if duct is run running in
your python shell you actually don't
have to import the data at all I
mentioned we can directly read Panda
data frames and error tables so and and
you don't even have to register them
because what we can do is when you use a
table name in a SQL query like so for
example um select Min from SDF like SDF
is not a table inductive if you haven't
created that table but it exists as a
variable in your python environment and
we will look at your P environment when
we looking for tables we'll find the
data frame read it and B basically go
okay you want to have the minimum value
fine here is 2. some milliseconds so
that's really convenient because you can
kind of get back and forth between data
frames and SQ like sort of
interactions okay so now I want to
continue with my slides and I'm not
going to do the presenter display
because that's um that's going to marck
with us uh how we on time by the way
you're good you're good how much so you
got another five minutes perfect for the
QA okay great thank you um so one more
thing that I want to talk about and I
know this is like super cliche and just
wanted to do it one thing that we've
also noticed in data management while
you know doing research and data
management systems is that people use
like these ginormous
hammers like distributed systems like
you know a spark cluster with 50 Buck 50
boxes or something like that to crack
like these tiny tiny nuts of data
problems like you know a 15 me 50
megabyte parket file or something like
that and it's I think I get it people
don't think about that a lot but I feel
like a this costs money uh and B I feel
like you using more resources than
necessary in this day and age is not
really a good look so but I understand
that people are used to their apis and
people are kind of you know they they
have their mode of operation and it
works for them and it's it's a lot of
effort to learn a new API like if you
told your team tomorrow you need to stop
start using dub and they'll go like but
yeah but then you know you need to stop
giving us tasks for for four weeks
before before we have to learn this
thing um so we have been working on
solving this
problem project named duck
spark and what duck spark is I will show
you in another demo
okay so let me let me restart this
um okay so now I have another demo yes
and I'm just gonna run through you
through a TP very sort of normal py
spark data analysis script okay so we
are just going
to import P spark and then we making
another 2 million for some reason 2
million is the magic number with these
old things uh data frame like it looks
it's random numbers it's very very un
like
unexciting um and then I'm using I'm
doing the usual dance of pulling up a
local Spar cluster okay it's doing
warnings it always does that um
and then I can basically tell uh spark
to take my local data frame and make a a
magic spark data frame out of it and if
you ever used this API you kind of know
that this is like a lazy data frame so
now I have
this spark data frame okay and now I can
do things with it so here is the spark
API I can say show me what it is in
there okay more Java warnings
um I can also run SQL queries because in
in spark of course they have a SQL and
sort of engine and you can basically run
like queries like this one where you say
oh give me like the you know the group
count on these random numbers which is
very you know it's not very useful but
um and I can look at the result and see
that more warnings okay and see like the
counts of these numbers it's not it's
you have seen this you have seen SE
logorithm before the nice thing about
these um the spark API the P spark API
though is that you also have this lazy
API where you can construct queries
right so if you doing Interactive L you
can be like filter do groupy dot blah
blah blah and it's all lazy and it will
be only evaluated um again this is oops
you get to laugh at my typing skills uh
it only will be executed whenever you
want to look at the results or top end
in this case yeah okay so far so
good so now what we have done is I take
this script and I change this variable
fast to True okay
yeah I know it's mean um and then what
happens oops let me actually restart
this sorry
um python because I don't want to so now
I have I generate the same data set
again okay fine so we have the data set
and then I'm using the same exact python
code to do things only that I don't see
the Java warnings that's
odd and it's somehow
snappier and I can do the exact same
thing so I'm copying just copy pasting
the exact same
code
uh and the result rendering looks
suspiciously
better and I can also use the exact
same um spark sort of dot filter do
groupy and so and so
apis um to to construct queries and
again see this weirdly different looking
um result so that in a very nutshell is
duck spark and so what duck spark is is
basically our um attempt of like
lowering the barrier for people coming
from pisar to go try dub without having
to require without having to spin up
distributed systems it can run there
right there on your laptop it can run on
a VM whatever you prefer it's API
compatible we aiming for like a full
python API compatibility so that
basically means if you have a script
that runs in py spark you can just use
it on on Duck DB and it will just run we
are we are working on like expanding
this to the full API this is not yet in
duct DB so you can't use it yet but it
will be soon hence it's a preview um and
we're really excited to see what people
can come up with so to sum up per um I
was talking about duct DB and in process
uh analytical data management system so
like things like sqlite but then for
analytics it's simple
it's just installs like with Pip install
it's really like has a lot of features
it's very fast and it's free and you get
to choose all four it's very deeply
integrated with python and pandas and
arrow and all these things we also have
features to go like from Duck DB to
tensorflow or from Duck DB to pie torch
in order to kind of go with ML workflows
wasn't time to talk about that um yeah
as I said P duv we have a Discord
channel so you can talk to us um we are
on
X seems so wrong I'm sorry uh and yeah
happy to take questions thank
[Music]
you